hi i'm ryan right and i'm gerry welcome
two reasons to see where we give you
reasons to see and not to see especially
today a hangover part 3 so let's get
[ __ ] up
Cassie I'm hungry mom and with a
customer she's rude you hear that
nobody's likes you yeah keep your mouth
shut Oh reason to see number one
there aren't any yeah this movie uh it
sucks reason not to see number one
bradley cooper and helms um talk about
the most bored looking people in a
comedy I've ever seen they didn't have
anything doing this would be hardly at
all oh yeah that seem like they just
wanted to capitalize on Zach
Galifianakis and push them to the side I
don't even dislike their their what they
did in this movie is just that they
weren't given anything to do Bradley
Cooper I was so surprised by he looked
like he was sick of this franchise him
in like every scene what are you doing
why why are you doing this I almost feel
like that's also how that character must
feel how Phil must feel just be like you
know I should have known better than to
go anywhere with you people like and
Eddie Helms to is uh people got annoyed
at him for just freaking out all through
the hangover part two so it's like they
tried finding that level where he could
freak out but it wasn't too much so
instead it was just another board guy in
the movie yeah well yeah cuz they don't
again it's like they didn't give him
really that much to do and then her much
just scenes where like stressful things
start to happen and then just come to
ten minutes later and it's like oh well
I guess they've resolved that yeah
reason not to see number two ciao I'm a
stereotypical tiny guy I like chowing
the first one but he's only good at
dosages well he does not give a main
character it's like what the [ __ ] and
there you have hips the main problem of
this movie is that it should and
challenge one of these one of these
elements is it chooses to focus on
things that worked the first time
because they were in small doses yeah
when you make all that stuff to focus it
all falls apart it's like some studio
said hey people laughed at this the
amplify it now yeah yeah it's like take
all that stuff regardless of why it
works and make that the focus of this
movie and that is Chow like that it's
challenge that Galifianakis yeah and
which I oh my goodness he used to be
funny now he's just this annoying
irritating brat who gets like the lead
role in this movie and then
like every 10 minutes is like ciao
what's wrong with you ciao you're crazy
ciao wow this guy's out of control jets
I we know how much you guys accepted
this about the planets like you think
you would get that yeah reason not to
see number three it's not funny okay so
this was kind of like identity thief to
me I said they're going that's a joke
it's not I'm not laughing at it I kid
you not I saw so many people walk out of
this movie there are tons of jokes there
are tons of things that are supposed to
be funny but it's I I was like who wrote
this because it felt like a 14 year old
Roman every Joe it's like after a while
it started to be like oh and then he's
gonna do that and they're gonna make
this silly joke and then you know this
is a Bradley Cooper head elms gonna be
like that's weird dammit strange there
are some of the most like contrived
jokes in this movie the problem is it
loses all the interesting edges the
first movie had its way I respected them
for going for a different structure and
it's darker like so it's a lot darker
like what's weird to me is this felt
kind of like a thriller but it's zach
elephant augenstein chao with as comic
relief or something so your colony has a
balance and there are different statuses
younger straight men you have your more
comedic characters and they're all funny
to an extent but when you take the most
ridiculous guys and make that the only
thing it's like what movie is this man
yeah you can't franchise this plot I
feel like the only way they could have
done this properly because a the
condition to call this a hangover part 3
yeah you know well I didn't know buddy I
don't know for nobody drinks anything he
so the only thing that felt close to its
feeling like the hangover was the
post-credit scene yeah well because it
yeah because if it harks back right to
the first it's the firts the only seen
that feels like this is the vibe that
should have existed for the last two
hours but if they went with that plot
that would have been a much more
interesting movie because i thought the
hangover 2 yeah it does fall the same
structures part 1 but I thought hangover
I laughed way more apart to that I did
that this was what decisions Zach
Galifianakis Zach Galifianakis
I have to admit he was the one thing
that had me laugh a few times in this
movie I wanted him to be honors like
he's the one thing that might make you
laugh there's one scene he has with a
kid that i did--like however he is one
of the biggest reasons this movie
doesn't work for me I liked him a lot
the first hangover and I thought he
worked really well in the dynamic that
first movie had and what happened is
when I was afraid of what would happen
was basically that they would take that
and be like oh people like Zach
Galifianakis let's let that persona go
nuts and then you get due date and then
you get all these other movies and sans
the indie ones this movie is pretty much
about Zach Galifianakis going nuts and
saying crazy things and being the focus
and it's like it sinks the ship Ryan's
consensus there are literally no reasons
to see the hangover part 3 there are
literally no reasons to see the hangover
part 3 I've said on the show that
certain movies suck the biggest fattest
balls but no this movie has found those
balls the biggest balls open its mouth
and is now chugging away at the biggest
balls ever Jerry's consensus um that
there are there aren't any reasons to
see that hangover 3 there aren't any
reasons to see the hangover 3 I this
movie just bummed me out you know it was
tedious i I didn't I wanted to like it I
wanted them to figure it out and they
sort of colossally didn't it's one of
the worst movies i've seen all year
alright guys thanks for checking out our
show why don't you go ahead scroll that
comment box below and tell us which one
is your favorite one out of the wolf
pack and which one do you consider
yourself to be and if you want to check
out more episodes of reasons to see go
ahead and click this link right here and
if you want to check out my straight to
the point review of why the hangover
part 3 sucks click on the link right
here and if you want to get updated
every time a new review or a video is
out subscribe click this box
motherfuckas symbol like chowder sound a
little bit like a little child really I
was channeling my Sandra Bullock from
the heat you know you know what mist was
a could really use some jeff chang this
movie oh yeah Shane would have been cool
Jeff fishing you a crossover movie that
would be fun I think the World Bank
meets the guise of 21 and over yeah you
know I might I might go back one more
time come get those original writers bag
you know crop summer movies are the
thing now yeah right it's like it's like
you hey like one thing that's done it
and now that we wanted from everything
Jeff Chang vs predator it's me yeah